Hello, I'm Simon Whistler, you're watching TodayIFoundOut and in the video today...
On the Far Side
For 15 years, Gary Larson took millions of
readers over to the “Far Side.”
Using anamorphic animals, chubby teenagers,
universal emotions, a simple drawing style
and a really bizarre, morbid sense of humor,
The Far Side became one of the most successful
– and praised – comic strips of all time.
But like many cartoonists, Larson has remained
rather elusive.
In 1995 (about 11 months before the creator
of Calvin and Hobbes did the same), he abruptly
ended the comic strip – perhaps even a bit
prematurely according to many of his fans.
So, how did Larson get to the “Far Side?”
And what was with his fascination with making
aliens look stupid?
Larson was born in 1950 – in the midst of
the baby boomer generation – in a blue-collar
neighborhood of Tacoma, Washington.
His father was a car mechanic, someone who
didn’t mind getting a bit dirty, which was
a trait he passed on to his two sons.
Larson has often reminisced about how he and
his brother would wade in the nearby Puget
Sound looking for critters like octopi and
salamanders, several of which would end up
in his later comics.
As he explained to the New York Times in 1998,
this love of wildlife has continued throughout
his life.
He originally was even a biology major at
Washington State University before deciding
that he wasn’t into all that schooling.
“I didn’t want to go to school for more
than four years, and I didn’t know what
you did with a bachelor’s in biology,”
Larson told the Times, ”so I switched over
and got my degree in communications.
I regret it now.
It was one of the most idiotic things I ever
did.”
Throughout his adult life, he was a keeper
of exotic pets including tarantulas, African
bullfrogs, Bermuda pythons, Mexican king snakes,
and carnivorous South American ornate horned
frogs.
Also, through high school and college, he
got really into jazz, both listening and playing.
And he was pretty talented, especially on
the guitar and banjo.
All of this is to say that being a cartoonist
was not originally part of Larson’s career
plan- he was never even terribly good at drawing.
Unlike many cartoonists of his era, Larson
says that he more or less fell into it.
In the mid-1970s, his jazz career was slowing
getting better and better until he was passed
over for a gig he thought he was going to
get with an established band.
Upset, loathing his job at a music store (establishments
which are, as he put it, “graveyards of
musicians”), and in need of money, Larson
began to draw animals, poorly.
While at the aforementioned day job at a music
shop in 1976, he drew one-panel cartoons featuring
animals making pithy, weird jokes.
Then, Larson sent them into local Seattle
magazine Pacific Search and, much to his surprise,
they purchased six of them for $90 (about
$400 today).
He thought this was the easiest money he had
ever made, so he kept doing it.
Soon after, a small weekly Tacoma publication
called the Sumner News Review purchased his
cartoons – which he had now named Nature’s
Way due to the fact that it was mostly about
animals – for $3 a pop.
Looking at Nature’s Way today, one can spot
many similarities to Far Side (which was still
a few years away).
The comic humanized animals, making them talk,
banter, and act like we do.
As for the humans, they were often chubby,
goofy-looking and not particularly bright.
In other words, it seems rather clear that
Larson has always held animals in a higher
regard than his fellow humans.
After a brief hiatus from publication, around
1978 or 1979, the Seattle Times gave Nature’s
Way a weekly space next to the “Junior Jumble”
puzzle, with Larson now earning five times
as much per week- a whopping $15 per comic
(about $50 today).
While a paid cartoonist, $15 per week isn’t
enough to live off of so Larson went to work
as an animal cruelty investigator for the
Seattle Humane Society.
According to a story he told Salon, on the
way to the interview for the job, Larson accidentally
hit a dog with his car…
To him, that was signal that perhaps this
line of work wasn’t meant to be for him.
(He also said that the dog ended up being
okay.)
So, on the side, he kept making his comics.
Trying to gain a second revenue stream, he
drove to San Francisco in an attempt to sell
Nature’s Way to the San Francisco Chronicle.
Admittedly, it was a stab in the dark.
He sat for hours in the reception area and
later called in twice a day to see if anyone
had looked over his work.
The most he got in response at this stage
was a bit of sympathy from the receptionist.
It was set-up to be a disappointment, but
much to his astonishment, when the paper did
finally get back to him, it turned out the
editors not only loved his comic, but instead
of running it weekly, they wanted it daily.
On top of that, they weren’t just going
to run it in one newspaper, but were going
to syndicate it to start across 30 newspapers!
Their only request was that Larson switch
the name from Nature’s Way to one they had
come up with- The Far Side.
As to that name change, Larson stated, “They
could have called it Revenge of the Zucchini
People for all I cared.”
The point was that between the switch to daily
and being syndicated, he could now make a
living doing the comic full time.
This was a fortunate turn of events as that
very same week the Seattle Times sent him
a letter noting they were canceling Nature’s
Way citing that they were getting too many
complaints that the comic was weird and offensive.
If he hadn’t just gotten the deal with Chronicle,
he later told Rolling Stone Magazine, that
“I’m certain I would have bagged it all.”
As noted, the San Francisco Chronicle put
the comic in 30 newspapers nearly immediately
and quickly audiences took to the weird, morbid
humor.
Well, at least, some did.
Through the comic’s decade and a half run,
newspapers across the country got an assortment
of complaint letters about the comic, mostly
with people stating that they found the cartoon
disturbing or offensive.
Some said that Larson needed “psychotherapy”
while others just wanted their “Annie”
back.
In the early days, the San Francisco Chronicle
editors, unlike the Seattle Times‘, simply
didn’t care.
They thought the comic was the work of genius.
But as for the steady stream of complaints,
this always took Larson by surprise with him
telling the Associated Press in 2003, “You
start off thinking that everyone in the world
has the same sense of humor as your six friends.
I was surprised at just how upset some people
could be.”
Among the massive fan base that The Far Side
would eventually develop, interestingly scientists
and academics were among the first to take
to the comic, despite Larson’s frequent
jabs at this very same group.
For example, perhaps the most famous Far Side
comic shows an image of a chubby boy with
glasses and holding books attempting to enter
the “Midvale School for the Gifted.”
He’s trying to push the door open while
it’s clearly marked pull.
Or the one where a group of scientists are
trying to figure out an equation only to be
interrupted by the ice cream truck.
Or this classic where the scientist realizes
the glass he’s holding is lemonade and not
a culture of amoebic dysentery.
Next to him another scientist is casually
sipping a glass of what he thinks is lemonade.
The strip also had a tangible impact on the
world of paleontology.
In an 1982 comic, a group of cavemen are in
lecture hall being shown a slide of a dinosaur.
The caveman instructor is pointing to the
spiky tail of a Stegosaurus while saying,
“Now this end is called the thagomizer…after
the late Thag Simmons.”
As it turned out, in real life, no one had
actually given that part of the Stegosaurus’
tail a name.
Despite Larson’s fudging of the facts (in
actuality, dinosaurs and humans missed each
other by more than 140 million years), paleontologists
adopted “thagomizer” as the official name
of the spikes on a Stegosaurus.
A decade and a half and over 4,000 comics
later, with a new premise for each cartoon
(as opposed to normal comic strips, which
could extend a premise for weeks and use repeating
characters to further simplify things) and
Larson was burnt out.
In 1994, he announced his retirement citing
that he wanted to avoid “the Graveyard of
Mediocre Cartoons.”
The final strip was published on January 1,
1995 and it was different than any other Far
Side.
It was two panels.
At the peak of his comic’s run, it appeared
in over 2,000 newspapers and, all told, Larson
has sold over 50 million Far Side books; that’s
not to mention the annual desk calendar version
that Larson describes as tantamount to “printing
money” every year.
Today, Larson lives a quiet life in Washington
state, constantly maintaining that he wants
to remain out of the spotlight.
Among a few other projects, he’s gone back
to jazz and can be sometimes seen performing
in clubs with his band, and even the occasional
wedding.
While it’s been more than two decades since
Larson retired from drawing cows, snakes,
and chubby kids, the comic still resonates.
Where else could you find out the real reason
dinosaurs went extinct?
So I really hope you enjoyed that video, and don't forget to subscribe to this channel for brand new videos
every day of the week. Also, I've got another channel, it's called TopTenzNet
its content very much like this one, just in a top 10 format!
You can check it out through the icon on the screen now.
But if you want something else to watch right now,  why not check out another
TodayIFoundOut video or indeed a TopTenz video, over there on the right. And thanks for watching!